hey everyone welcome to live coding with
Jessie today we're going to continue
with our live search component and we're
gonna try first to search through a lot
more than we attempted to search through
last week just to see what kind of
performance we get when we do a search
like that and you know how many entries
were likely to get on you know a single
search and then after we see what that
looks like on the page I think we can
continue on with kind of building out
the UI so that's the plan for today I do
have a meeting in two hours so like the
stream to be about you know now
somewhere between an hour and hour and a
half I should give us plenty of time to
get some things done and you know answer
a lot of questions I hope everyone had a
good weekend I I wasn't feeling well
like Saturday so I actually really
wanted to do a lot of coding get things
done on Saturday and I ended up not so
so it was it was weird and just mental
health update and to help anyone else
out there so I was feeling a little bit
sick Saturday and my my kids were at my
parents and my wife was gone so it was
like I hadn't worked out in a day or two
because I wasn't feeling well I was just
by myself I was trying to get a lot of
stuff done feeling a little bit
overwhelmed and my depression and
anxiety were just really bad so it maybe
was a combination of you know a lot of
different factors of
you know this the sickness not
exercising you know being lonely and you
know all those factors I think may be
combined so this is just something for
me to watch out watch out for and maybe
for for you all to watch out for if
you're dealing with the same kind of
kind of thing so I was kind of really
pumped to be able to get all the stuff
done but you know I just couldn't and so
I'm gonna have to watch out for that
next time and maybe come up with a
different plan you know to keep myself
up and and on target when I'm not really
feeling well so all right so let's get
onto some coding so we have a lot more
people watching now I wanted to wait
till we had a few more people in until I
share this link here is the end rot link
for this project so if you click on that
link you'll be able to see the project
that I'm locally working on you'll be
able to see that in your browser and
anytime I make changes it'll be
reflected immediately in your browser so
you can use dev tools on it and search
around in different pages and you know
you're not limited to just seeing what I
happen to have on my screen at any given
time I am now going to switch so that
you all can see what's what's happening
all right Michael said I know the
feeling went through the same things
this weekend yeah I am I'm feeling a
little bit better now like mentally way
I'm feeling I'm feeling better yeah but
it was just yeah Saturday was just a
weird weird day
but did get some good news over the
weekend so Saturday night Saturday
evening at some point I found out that I
was accepted to speak at the moms can
code virtual summit so it's it's like a
week-long conference
it's all online and there are 40
speakers 39 of the speakers are women I
I'm the only man that got accepted so
I'm I guess I'm pretty honored to be on
that list and I feel pressure that I
guess I need to do a good job to justify
me being on on that list but anyway
that's that's really cool I'm excited
about that and that'll be sometime in
April so you'll see me I'll be tweeting
about that one more info comes out okay
so let's all right that was a different
page I was working on so I've been
working on the data we have stored in
WordPress trying to get things in shape
because you know some of it came over in
fragments we're like we have a page but
then each section of the page came over
as a different post type so I'm trying
to consolidate those and just make sense
of them
michael says Congrats I think have they
seen the picture of you with the beard I
don't know what picture they saw good
pictures this of me so yeah I mean some
of my social media pictures and a lot of
my videos I don't have a beard so I
don't I don't know so let's go to the
search page and if you want to follow
along on your computer our search page
is just slash search so first thing I
want to do is start this Pomodoro timer
so we do our first coding session and
then let's go in and add post types onto
our search query that we were doing so I
was working on this page and let me push
this I just committed my changes and now
they're on github all right so now the
code on github is completely up to date
with what I have here locally I also I
don't know how many of you remember or
following along at all with one of the
side projects that I'm working on that
was a JavaScript AF and we had a lot of
we had a lot of ideas for the site but I
think we're narrowing the focus I don't
want to have a site with a bunch of
different features and none of them not
have enough time to really perfect any
of them I'd rather have a site that does
one thing really well so we're focusing
this site on being a place where you can
find and share really cool github repos
like javascript github repos so it'll
just have a nice UI and whereas the site
github is not focused so much on
discovering new repos and being able to
search for them you can do that but the
focus is being able to actually update
merge and maintain repositories this
site is not going to have any of that
it's just gonna have a really kind of
nice search function and you know
potentially a way to upvote repositories
and try to share I'd really like to get
some of these some of the things that
people are working on that aren't really
well-known maybe they don't have a lot
of stars to get those some more exposure
to the community especially some maybe
the more unique things that are
happening with JavaScript I think it'd
be cool to highlight so if anybody's
interested in that at all you have any
ideas or feedback or you'd like to
contribute to that
check out my github repo the project is
JavaScript
- AF and then we also have an API hard
just came in the live chat and I will
mention that Harshit has done the
majority of the coding for this project
unfortunately I've been too busy over
the last month to contribute much in the
way of code so I guess I've been kind of
guiding things just with with ideas and
encouragement for now and Harsha's on a
ton of the work so thank you to harsh it
for that but I welcome anyone else to
you know be involved if you want to it's
it's a react project so if you're
interested in reactors that and then
Harsha and it could tell you more than a
live chat about how we're building how
he's building the backend and the API
part of it
if anyone's if anyone's interested all
right so here's our search page where's
our oops this is probably so small I
apologize there we are okay so I'm on
the search page so if you are following
along locally or in the repository it's
in the pages folder in its search j/s
and we're down here at the I could
shrink this up a bit
and this makes
more space so this is that that query
that I was talking about see see right
now we're not really getting that many
post types so we're getting admissions
pages and chapel pages so I just want to
keep adding on a few more types and I'm
gonna on my other screen I'm gonna check
out some of the types we have so I can
add them in quickly so let's go one two
three four five let's try to add five
types for now so we can have let's just
have let's see faculty and major and I
think all of these are singular if they
don't work I guess then we'll find out
and Department see what else most of you
have
academics page
one more what's it gonna be
if I include news it's gonna be a lot
well I want to test see what we can
handle so let's include news in here
alright so I'm gonna save that and let's
see if it works
we'll just search for a really common
word see if we get back a lot okay see
we're getting here so we got a
department admissions pages chapel page
academics major okay but it looks like
we didn't get anything from News which
is odd I mean I'm pretty sure the word
the is his in some of these news posts
see did I mess up that last one and type
news
I may have to check to see how I put
news in there in our custom plugin
yeah news it should be news I didn't use
yeah news was the rest yeah so I had for
the rest API
that's pretty weird not sure what's
going on there
let's see if if there's some sort of
limit and so let's move news up here I
don't need this type post or type page
because we don't have anything in posts
or pages right now anyway
okay
search I can't tell if the searched
again or not
okay we're still not getting any news
it's weird
I listen to see
all right not really sure why that's
happening with the news pages I'm gonna
check the live chat here to see if if
any of you said anything about that or
if you're getting different results on
your your local version
all right
I wonder
alright let me know what you all think
about this so clearly we're not getting
everything that we could be getting here
for some reason we're getting nothing
from news not even if I search for news
there we are finally so we did get news
now this is I wonder I don't think I
have any caching setup
yeah
all right this
I wonder if it's limiting our results by
that 100
maybe that's it I mean I'm not gonna
count these but I figure we're probably
getting a hundred if I can get a number
here yep we're getting a hundred results
so we're limited to that hundred which
is not bad so we do all right
here's here's my idea let's
we're just gonna have to do either a
button here that says more results or do
an infinite scroll since we are limited
by that 101 100 posts for a search
I don't well I'll tell you what it has
been a while since I checked the API
documentation for WordPress it used to
be and it might still be that you
couldn't go over that 100 limit let's
see if you can now let's just let's say
500 I yeah I don't think this will work
I think 100 is like a hard limit but
we'll we'll test it
whoa yeah so that that must have given
us an error when we tried to
see
and did we have area
what's fun over using we don't have the
the limit here it's gonna say we could
see exactly I suspect we're getting this
back I will copy and paste that into
here so we can see what's happening
we'll give it this per page 500 let's
see
whoops who's over here
and
okay we're getting something back but
it's definitely not oops
this isn't what I need right I made that
I did that wrong no rest route and that
is how we have it in here will pose now
I flipped it around sorry about that
okay so that's an invalid parameter we
can't use 500 we can't use 200 we can't
use 101 so I think it is still 100 as
the limit okay yep all right so we're
limited to 100 limited 100 here it's not
going to be a huge problem I said we can
do the search the infinite scroll type
of search or have users hit a button
either way and then we're going to have
a lot of options for users to choose
exactly what type of content they want
so assuming that they're only choosing
one type of content like let's say they
only want faculty members to come up in
their search we're fine we're now going
to go over the limit especially if
they're saying I only want faculty
members and I want them from this
specific department or I want the
faculty member that has this name right
there that's going to be okay the news
will probably be the only post type that
it really has more than hey sorry let's
try to hold back a yawn
so yea News definitely has more than a
hundred so that will come into play if
somebody searches a very common term and
wants to know about news hmm
okay yeah we're just gonna have to deal
with that so I think I think we're okay
right now yeah we're okay right now
let's work on some of those let's work
on some of the filters then I think
before Before we jump into UI stuff kind
of like wow my mind is still on that
search query I think it would be a good
time to do that if I switch back into
like design mode it'll be harder to
switch back if I want to do it so let's
just put in some some test filters and
see how they're gonna work so what will
happen then is this whole portion of
n-type news and all that that those are
going to be variables just like search
term is so let's see how we'll do this
so let's take this and type news and
copy that that's going to be the
template and we're getting the search
term right now from that gets saved and
state I believe and why are we not okay
let's see
there's our input
all right so we have on change get
search results so let's go up til I get
search results function search good ok I
don't know what I was thinking so search
term is passed into this function I'm
not sure I want it to happen like that
I think I may rather have the input be a
controlled component so it actually goes
up here and in state and then we don't
pass anything through here we can just
run it from whatever's happens to be in
state at that time so let's let's do
that so first thing we're gonna do we're
gonna change this and we're going to say
search term and we're just gonna
initialize that to an empty string not
equals we initialize that to an empty
string so for a search term it's we're
gonna say this state search term and we
don't need this anymore
and then down here we're gonna call
fetch search term but we don't need that
search value anymore and then here and
put on change we're gonna put a value ID
and there it's gonna get its value from
this
now we don't let's just say search term
whoops
and we're going to whoops not under
props we're gonna do this and we're
gonna say search term and now we're
gonna say this state and what are my
lines for not search CR CH T or and why
can't I do that I'm pretty sure I can do
that right
okay
let me check my time while I'm over here
okay only about a minute left so let's
just see if this works now well let me
type in okay this state data map is not
a function X as I didn't get any data
oops
that's weird
okay I messed something up in this flow
of let's see search term oh okay
I'm not actually changing event default
concert so it's unfocused keyword so I'm
not actually setting setting state so
I'm gonna set the stay here this set
states and we're gonna go search term
search
Hey
so it I have a floor
no it's not working
dony I think I need something else okay
I would say our Christopher said it
should be this state equals you did
state equals all right what line was
that
okay yeah all right all right let me let
me set my five-minute timer so I can go
back to the live chat and answer some
questions then I'll come back and
troubleshoot why why the values not
working for that that inflated I suspect
I'm just messing something up syntax why
somewhere hey everybody who said hi at
the beginning I forgot to say hi to you
off also thanks for everyone saying
congratulations for me being able to
speak at the moms can code summit a
noble and savage says you big rough
rough looking man with giggle haha also
says how he all doing I just started
that 100 days thing to give me motivated
to do many hours a day awesome my wife
still in the hundred days of code as
well so that's that's really cool I hope
you hope you do all your days and learn
a lot and build cool stuff all right
Nikki has a crypto question so I
mentioned it last week that I started
doing a tutorial to build distributed
apps on the ethereum blockchain using a
language called solidity I think its
solidity um and the tutorial is crypto
zombies that I uh
Sonique es is it going out to the
Internet
every time that zombie eat kitty
function runs so true the blockchain to
be specific I think so I think how that
I did that lesson yeah so I think all
those
assuming that it's connected up to the
blockchain like and not in some sandbox
environment then I think all of those
main functions or do go through the
blockchain which I guess makes sense
right because then that would that would
change like important information
because you would get a new zombie so
it'd be a new zombie with new DNA
assigned to your specific ID so I do I
believe so but I'm still going this
route through the tutorial I'm on lesson
five now no but I'm not not at all an
expert on it okay I should say and maybe
show the progress on the test domain for
the JavaScript raf project yeah we'll
see how much time is left after I get
your questions and stuff and after this
next Pomodoro session and then we may do
that or maybe if not today then I'm sure
at some point this week we can we can
show it off a bit
okay Chris you're saying doesn't npm
sort of do that JavaScript they have
thing well I guess I mean NPM doesn't
have NPM wouldn't necessarily have all
the the projects there's so like not
every JavaScript project on github is
also an NPM unless I'm wrong and let me
know if I'm wrong about that
and I do want your honest opinion about
the project Rea because if if you all
think that it's a ridiculous idea this
this github repo search thing with
JavaScript dot AF let me know because
I'd rather not spend a bunch of time
working on something that's that nobody
wants or nobody thinks will be useful so
constructive criticism is definitely
welcome I may try to do some live
streams on my own channel where I work
on that project and then that way you
all can get kind of a better idea of
what's going on Christopher says on your
Franciscan page the nav links probably
need some indication of hub or other
than mouse pointer send these ones yeah
let me think ok so I I'm I'm not a
hundred percent sure I want to add
another indication but if we were to add
another indication that these are
clickable what should it be
so I'm up for suggestions here keep in
mind I would like it to be as material
design issue as possible
but let me know if we're gonna have
anything I would like it to be subtle I
don't want a lot of crazy motion or
something like that no like text getting
a lot bigger stuff but I'm I am open to
subtle something subtle I'll at least
consider that if you all think it would
it would really help okay
so didn't quite get through all the
questions this time we'll get to the
rest of them after this next Pomodoro
session
alright let me reset the timer and let's
figure out what I did wrong why this
isn't working
alright so let me let me walk through
the flow of what should happen then so
initially initially a search term and
state to be an empty string so initially
the value in our input should be search
term and we should be able to get search
term from here right that's why we don't
need to write this state down here then
on change it goes to this dot get search
results so let's go up there let me see
as well as psycho searches so when we go
to get search results
oops
all right I see what the problem is I
did this all in the wrong place
shoot I'm gonna have to undo a lot of
stuff here
I'm gonna be copy this
so I had we left in some there we go
yeah yeah we I left in some functions
that we may need at some point but right
now we don't need so that's kind of
that's what happened there all right so
what I need to do then is go call this
set state and put in a search term and
set that equal to value okay and the
reason we're doing that before we do
this is that this is going to determine
the value of that input so I don't want
to debounce or check for length of that
input right so otherwise I'd be able to
type two characters and nothing would
show up in my input all right so that's
that's not what what we want so we want
state to get set immediately and then we
can also check here to make sure before
we actually search anything that what
we're debouncing so we don't search too
many times and we're also not going to
search for tiny strings okay so with
that and that let's go down here and add
this back in and let's add our value
back in the value is gonna equals search
term
and this makes sure nothing changed I
don't believe we went back so far that
anything else changed yet up here okay
let's say that see if it works
there we are okay good so now our just
to show what's what's really happening
let's go into react and make this bigger
maybe too big make this whole thing big
there we go so here's our search term in
our state and we say it says the now so
if I go back we have a th there so you
see every time I type this is updated so
this is what we call a controlled input
a controlled component we're essentially
on a good way to remember this is the
value of the input is controlled by
state so when you type something in
state is updated so the dataflow as you
type state is updated and then the value
of the component gets updated so as soon
as state changes a rerender happens and
when that rerender happens the value of
this input is changed based on the value
state okay so that's how the flow goes
it may not seem like it makes a lot of
sense or adds any benefit here when we
only have one input but as we continue
to add our filters on it does you'll see
that it does make it easier when you
have more form input so these that's
been what I found is is that it's it is
nicer in in those cases
okay
I think let's let's commit that right so
I think this is enough of a feature that
we can commit this before we add in some
more inputs so I'm going to again status
make sure of what we changed get add and
then we'll do our yarn CM so this is
particularly this project we have kind
of a special kind of format that it
takes you through so you can see this
let's do a refactor yeah who do you
think refactor would be appropriate oh
yeah we'll say refactor and we're just
gonna say
we factor search input to be a
controlled input okay great
and this doesn't break anything and it
does not affect any open issues now it's
going to roll the tests once it passes
we can commit this to our github repo
great whoops get push origin there we
are okay
all right so now that we have that all
sorted we can add in our filter there so
this is what I was attempting to do at
first and then realize that we needed to
do some more work
so let's as I was trying to do before
grab this first one this type news just
as to use as our template I guess and
we're gonna let's see we're gonna create
an item and States how are you gonna do
this
all right I'm sure we'll refactor this
as we go on I'm gonna try something
first we'll test and see if it works and
then maybe it can be improved but so at
first we're gonna do search type and
this will be a string and let's just for
now we're just going to put search type
news in there and what do I need to grab
type news and do we want the end there
all the time
we went up we want the end to be here
okay so search site news and forget like
okay
and then we're going to let's take all
of this get rid of it for now even this
let's take all of this get rid of it for
now and throw it over here just kind of
in our scrap for the file and because
we'll refer to that a little bit later
but what we want to do back here where
we took all this stuff out is we want to
put in a class we could do
we'll just concatenate these two
the state search type right
why is this not working
you're
why is he giving me an error this state
search type
as we
okay
okay so it does work I don't I don't
know what was up with that error I guess
it didn't like that space in there but
you can see we've I don't know how if
it's easy to see this down at the bottom
here but we have our search did exactly
we have the search term though and then
the type equals news so now if we want
to change what we're searching for all
we have to do is change this in state
this search type so what we can do now
is add our inputs that are going to
change what we're searching and each one
of those will change this value here so
here's what I'm thinking it'll be check
boxes because we don't want to limit
users to only search one thing at a time
that would be I could see that as being
annoying that a user picked the wrong
category they're not sure exactly what
they want and they have to go through
like four different categories searching
for the same thing in each category
that's that's annoying what if they say
well I think it might be in one of these
four categories so I'm gonna search for
all four of these categories at once so
that's why I like the idea of checkboxes
as opposed to radio buttons so we will
have checkboxes for each of the search
items if you've ever been to amazon.com
you notice that on their search they go
mostly with the check boxes so we're
gonna go with something like that and so
each check box that's checked is going
to update what is in search type now
we're going to do this
this is what I was pausing to think
about before and I said I would just put
it off the best way to not only add to
this string but also remove items as
well
series
oh how about this what if instead of
just having search type to search tight
we have we had can we can we do this
search type
is let's go
majors do we have majored yet this would
be insight major faculty is gonna give
us okay so you get what I'm doing here
okay and then what we would do is map so
we would look through this so every time
the search happens you would loop
through this and then add these together
so essentially a search happens
everything's cleared then gets added
again and that's on search or that
happens on click of a checkbox so we
just go through and and add those in
yeah okay let me check the the live chat
because I think some of you are
commenting on this as well
oh okay Alexander's saying it's hard to
read the console you know what I I had
moved my where my my video shows up when
I made that so Friday afternoon I made a
I think it was Friday afternoon maybe
Thursday anyway I made a video about
installing node and and get and cloning
a repo to your local machine and getting
it up and running kind of just like a
beginner's basics video and I posted
that on my channel so if you're new to
get and github check that out maybe it
might it may be helpful for you
but anyway what I was doing in that
video made more sense for me to have my
thing over here and I forgot to move it
back thank you for bringing that up
though I apologize if this has been
covering things up the whole time john
hanson saying it could be an array of
objects michael says is there a way to
group checkboxes in a frame and then
build a search query of the check boxes
in the frame i know access could do it
john says you could also make those
default value as false and true on
checkbox
okay all right let's go let me let me
test things out which is these three
will make some check boxes and then see
if the concept itself is just working at
all and then we can refactor after that
l exam dove saying this state search
type as an array okay yeah actually we
could do it and I think somebody else
mentioned it as well as well what about
an array of objects yeah let's do an
array of objects that makes sense let's
see if it'll let me do this yes
but we don't need this to be defined
with you talking about
oops
all right they don't like that
Alexander says who you would separate
the URL creation from the logic
okay we need some checkboxes now should
we check material UI yeah whoops let's
check this component selects it's any
checkboxes click the wrong thing
wait there's got to be checkboxes
checkbox
yeah I'm just missing it in here Oh
selection controls that's what it was
under control
okay
let's see this one
I guess we can grab all of this
and we'll paste it for now we'll just
put it right below I know we have this
in a form tag but for now I'm going to
keep it separate we need form control
form label while we need a lot let's
just copy and paste
okay
so we're gonna have to change the values
of course just to make sure no the
sandals change is not a function alright
let's let's bring in the handle change
function as well I miss that
oh you know what I forgot we already
were pulling in some filter stuff it's
alright just to get this working for now
no change
alright cool so here's our our inputs
and I wanted to use the material UI ones
instead of just throwing in an input
like we did here because you know we see
we have styling built in so I'll
probably adjust the Styles a bit like
maybe add a little less space between
these but this is basically what we want
I don't have that much time left
no not enough time left so we need just
a price all right that's that's not what
we brought in
all right I'm at a time for this one
we're gonna have to save this I suppose
for tomorrow normally I would try to get
this done but since I have a meeting
coming up I can't I can't go to too much
longer so the plan then is and I may
just hold off and do this in the next
stream we'll see but the plan is just to
connect these so that when you check it
it does actually change something in
state and then once someone were would
search or click it takes everything in
States these strings and it makes one
large string and that's what gets
inserted into here so let's you know
let's change this now well I'm thinking
about it so we need get rid of this and
make that blank and then instead of
search type this needs to be checkboxes
there we go okay so now we can still say
where do you search type in here this
makes sense now we're saying these are
the check box values yeah
this may be over complicated to do it
like this it's all separate objects so
anyway that's that's basically what's
going to happen if that works then I'll
just add all the possible combinations
as check boxes that we want here and and
then we need to make clean up the UI a
bit so on a large screen you know we
could probably display all the options
and it wouldn't be an issue on mobile
we're gonna have to come up with some
other way to display all the options
probably some sort of toggle that would
display them and then hide them okay so
let me go back to our left off in the
live chat let me get a drink first
so I'm going to go back to where I left
off I'm gonna answer as many questions
as I can before my meeting I think I
should be able to get all the questions
and if you have any more questions
please put them in the live chat now
feel free also to ask me questions in
the comments of this video or to send me
a question on Twitter or Instagram
Facebook email whatever else you can
think of I can't always get back to you
right away but I do try to eventually
get back to everyone that asked me a
question
see
Guerlain says how do I gain abilities
like you just practice so I take some
like if you haven't already done it go
through some of the free chord free code
camp challenges you can check out some
of the free Udacity free or paid Udacity
courses just take advantage of a lot of
the online resources that are out there
to help you learn more about JavaScript
HTML and CSS if you're interested in
design I recommend reading through the
Google material design documentation if
you're not a fan of material design you
know check out apple's design stuff I
assume Microsoft has something similar
for their their style so just just to
give you an idea of you know all the
thought and and that goes into you know
designing a a nice looking and useful
user interface and then just practice
this keep building things if you can get
paid to build that's even better
but either way just keep building and I
mean that's that's really how it's done
there's no substitute just for
experience and in practicing so there's
a little bit every day if you can is is
great sandé says hey do you play csgo I
do not play csgo
so I'm not currently the only thing that
I've been playing and I don't really I
don't play every day as Zelda breadth of
the wild for Nintendo switch so
occasionally I will play that and some
usually like if I'm
hang out in the morning on exercise bike
sometimes I'll play
if divi Anshu says hi I just joined what
did I miss
we were so we tested out some of the
limits on the search in terms of how
many things we could search for at once
and we can search for a hundred things
at once we can't go past the hundred
thing limit we can search for a bunch of
different types of content all at once
but we're still limited by that hundred
thing limit we made an input into a
controlled input so just using state as
the value and then making sure we update
state every time we change that input
and then we add it in some check boxes
and those will eventually be used to
determine exactly what types of content
we will be searching for
John said congrats on the talk Thanks
thank you I appreciate it siphon siphon
X says are you reading this I am now
that's your if you're still here
I should say even you don't know how
large that codebase is gone I'm assuming
you're talking about the JavaScript AF
yeah I'm sure I I don't know how large
the code pieces because I haven't been
through it all so in that after saying
that hard [ __ ] I mean do you in your
opinion do you think it was a good call
to say we're just going to focus on one
thing instead of trying to do a lot of
different things just in terms of being
able to manage the repository will that
help you cutting things down
Aniki says kind of off topic but phantom
Jas is having drama and is being retired
luckily it kind of got replaced by
puppeteer while ago yes yes so I don't
know if if anyone knows about this but
so phantom Jas was open source project
there's just not enough people
maintaining it and so they are retiring
it I believe they said that it could be
revived at a later date but that's not
really guaranteed they would need more
people to get involved with the project
so so I guess I mean when things like
this happen it's good to remember these
open source projects only exist because
people donate their time to help keeping
them alive so if you have the ability
and the time to keep them alive please
please do that and contribute to the
projects maybe if if you don't have the
time or the ability to contribute maybe
consider can
tributing money to help keep these
projects alive
so either way that can be very helpful
John says anyone interested in the
upcoming changes in react should watch
the video sneak peek beyond react 16 on
the react JSL work blog a sync rendering
time slicing suspense and many other new
things yes definitely give that a watch
so ya go to react jest or go to the blog
check out the video the video is
embedded right there in the blog I
didn't watch the entire video I watched
at least half of it when it came out
last week very impressive very exciting
so I'm not gonna try to explain it
because I'm sure I'll mess it up I only
watched it once last week and only
halfway through so maybe if I go through
the video more and understand it a
little better maybe we'll talk about it
on the stream but it was cool like when
I got to the point in the video when I
was really starting to think about okay
how could I use this on my projects then
it's it started to get exciting it was
cool you know thinking about things I've
done in past projects that were kind of
a pain and in thinking wow if I had this
back then it would have been so much
better really really cool cool stuff
Fernando says hi Jesse I am from
Argentina
welcome thank you for watching
John Ensign says and this is about the
new reax there's no more need for
debounce yeah you're right I saw that
part so there's something that may be
coming in react so all these things in
reactor like not guaranteed yet none of
them are finished so they could change
but like there was a thing in there that
maybe it would make debounce
obsolete so we're using it in this
project right now if you just talked
about it earlier in the in the stream we
saw that line where we're debouncing so
we wouldn't need to do that
okay hard sink so that show the site if
time allows alright let me get through
these last few things in the live chat
horseshit and check the time Michael
says I've hit a brick wall with my free
code camp Simon I'm not great at
front-end but good at logic I've been
fighting a way to make it look good but
it breaks my logic is it better to look
bad but I'm nice logic or look nice and
have spaghetti code on the backend
it depends on who's looking at it right
from from a user's perspective I guess
as long as it works they would prefer
that it does look nice and they don't
care what the code looks like at all
they probably never think about it but
if you are going to be showing this to
death so if it's going to be on your
github repo then you probably do want
your code to look nice if it's something
you're going to go back to and have to
maintain you don't want spaghetti code
either so that's interesting that the
look of it is breaking the logic I said
hmm Michael do you have that on get that
project on github and would you mind if
I just took a look at it at some point I
can't I don't have a lot of time so I
can't guarantee I'd be able to do
anything but if I get a chance I'd like
to at least like just check it out so
let me know
chef in says hello I'm from Bangladesh
hi welcome thanks for watching Chris
says that's great advice
oh thanks thanks Michael says no no no
it was that a no no no to be looking at
it alright it's cool it's cool if you
don't wanted me to see it I understand
but uh alright
so I've gotten through everything the
live set so I guess I'll have a look
yeah let's let's have a look at the the
project here so hard [ __ ]
Harshit you want me to show the project
on the test URL are you cool with people
knowing the test URL right now I'm gonna
open it on my other screen and wait for
an answer here
all right some still I'm waiting for
response hopefully our she heard me I
just want to be sure that the test URL
can handle traffic and that it's okay
for people to know about it
okay there you go all the old stuff was
loading I had to refresh it okay cool so
let me let me pull this over and I'm
just gonna spend just a few minutes on
this because I will have to go to my
meeting soon but here's a sneak preview
of what
Harshit has been working on in doing
pretty much all the coding for
especially all the backend stuff and
I've been just somewhat involved and to
be honest but this is just a little
taste
we're not even in beta yet like we'd
like to have a beta at some point so
very much open to suggestions
the idea is you could go here to
discover new repositories you could
certainly have different criteria for
what you would want to how you want to
filter these and how do you want to sort
them and there will be some sort of way
to let's say upvote different
repositories so I would like it I'm not
gonna say right away that I'm going to
exclude the big repositories but I would
like to make it so that the big
repositories are not always on the top
right you know we you can always see
like react has it's honest you know
reacts up at the top like the the big
stuff from big companies are usually at
at the top of like the most starred
repositories so I everybody already
knows about those what I want to
highlight are some of the smaller ones
so I'm hoping that's what we'll do we'll
just have to kind of as we go through
beta testing and things we just have to
kind of adjust how we're pulling these
in to make sure that that happens
so here's some of the other things like
we have a feed our sugar we are we not
doing the feed at first I think that's
what what's happening so
I think I think we're not gonna have the
feed so there was some social media
components that we're gonna hold off
we're most likely I where either gonna
split it into another project or just
hold off on them and maybe think about
adding them back in at some point but
for now I think we're better off
focusing on one thing getting that ready
so we can actually get it released and
doing that one thing well we also had a
spot where we were gonna allow people to
post jobs so this is one of the other
things that may be added on as a feature
at some point obviously we're going to
have a search which this one currently
is searching for people and repositories
so for sure we're gonna have a
repository search I'll have to check
with Harshit on whether the people
search adds a lot more complexity or not
if it doesn't then we may keep that if
you know if not it might just be
repositories at first the messaging
thing that's another thing that Merriman
may not be available at first but could
be a feature later on I mean it was
working like yes there's no rooms here
right now it was working before so it's
not working right now but you know
that's that's how it is when it's in a
state of development and then of course
we have this is another one of those
social media elements that probably
won't be in there in terms of like
followers and things like that and yeah
so that's what we have so far should let
me know if I missed anything I should
saying the search works
oh really cool let's see
is it not is it just working for people
right now do we only have limited stuff
in there that's probably
all right okay horseshit saying it's
only working for people right now okay
all right so that's the basically the
idea behind it and I'm not indexed yet
that's all right so that's the idea
behind it I really just want I just want
it to be a place where you can go to get
inspiration and see what other people
are doing maybe figure out projects that
you would like to contribute to and just
have it be a very nice fast interface
this is all you know react based and
let's see hard saying test yeah so we
have the cool that's cool live search
and that's using algo Lea which is
pretty cool search service I like it
it's not free but I I think it's really
cool so anyway that's the idea
at least that at least at first I mean
this is gonna be totally free at some
point I might like to add in some
features like optional features that
could potentially bring in some revenue
to at least pay for servers and things
like that because if we did get a lot of
users I'd imagine it would get pretty
expensive so that's that's on the
horizon as being a possibility you know
the other alternative maybe is trying to
run off of donations and things like
that so first things first is let's get
it to a point where we can beta test it
see if anybody is even interested if we
even get any users and then you know
take we'll go from there
but the domain name will be JavaScript
AF which will make sense for a
javascript repository
you know site
yeah so anyway the the repo for this
project for the front-end react part is
JavaScript
- AF and that's on my github my github
account and then we also have the
backend is JavaScript - AF - API so you
can check out both of those Harshit
mentioned before you do need some
environment variables to get things up
and running for the different services
that we have so if you if you'd like to
work on it and contribute let probably
want to let hard [ __ ] know that you're
interested and then see about getting
what you need to get things up and
running yeah and we'll definitely need
beta testers - so even if you're not
interested in contributing code beta
testers are going to be important so
I'll make sure to let everyone know when
we're when we're at that point I think
we're pretty close to being able to do
some sort of you know beta like really
limited beta you know all right okay so
I'm gonna have to go now and get a few
things done before my meeting and I
should be back tomorrow I may have I got
a double check I may have another
presentation tomorrow it's not on my
calendar but my the head of my
department mentioned something about it
so I need to figure out what what's
going on with that so depending on what
happens with that
we'll see if I can stream or not and
what time I can stream but I want to try
to do there's many streams as I can this
week kind of get back in the swing of
things here Oh Michael I did not get a
chance to check out the node CD manager
I'm really sorry about that to be honest
with you I keep forgetting about it and
every time I see it in my github account
I just look I'm not at a point where I
can actually check it right
boys like in the middle of doing
something else so I will get to it I
can't tell you when but I will try so
apologies okay alright that's it for
today I really need to stop talking now
and I get ready for my next meeting I
really appreciate everyone watching
today and thanks for checking out this
project and thank you to everybody who
listened to me for a few minutes earlier
talking about my mental health I know
it's not very interesting for a lot of
you but I I think it's good for me and
it's good for other people in similar
situations to talk about stuff like that
so that's why I do it let's see okay see
add a few more more comments I was just
checking in the in the chat there but
anyway I'm gonna try my best to be back
tomorrow and until then have a great day
everyone